the Kardashian sisters giving back this
Christmas we're so happy to do Kim and
Chloe visited the Alexandria house in
Los Angeles a non-profit organization
that provides shelter Child Care and
More for hundreds of homeless women in
the area the sisters toured homes met
the staff volunteers and the women and
children currently in the transitional
program Kim and Chloe shared a ton of
photos from their trip including this
shot of Coco speaking to a group of
ladies and it seems they're teaching
their kids the importance of giving back
their daughter's true and North were
there along with their brothers Rob's
little girl dream I hope that they just
find their own motivation and no matter
what that is I hope that's motivating
for them and just to find their own path
now Alexandria house might sound
familiar Kim's visit to the home five
years ago was featured on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians today I have an
amazing party plan to support the
Alexandria house a long-term shelter for
women and single moms I just want want
to bring awareness to this issue because
I feel like there's a lot that can be
done in our community and it starts with
just getting the information
and on the beauty mogul's most recent
trip it was a special day for many of
the women as it included pampering
makeup Services by a Glam Squad and mini
portrait photo sessions for them and
their children in Chloe's caption she
praised founding director Judy Vaughn
and her staff saying quote it truly
takes a village and through the support
of community organizations such as
Alexandria house we can make the
difference in so many lives it's such a
beautiful thing and turns out Kim and
Chloe's momager Kris Jenner was also
part of it earlier in the week the mom
of six helped arrange for Christmas
lights to be installed at the homes and
made a six-figure cash donation makes me
so happy the smallest donation can
really make the biggest difference and
Kim and Coco offered a surprise of their
own over five thousand dollars in gifts
including laptops toothbrushes items
from their companies skims and good
American and much much more
foreign